un dictateur russe de renommée
envahissant un pays étranger a coûté
dans le monde entier
[Musique]
[Rires] [
Musique] il
y a six jours, le russe vladimir poutine a
cherché à ébranler les fondements mêmes
du monde libre en pensant qu'il pourrait le faire
plier à ses manières menaçantes mais  il a mal
calculé il a rencontré un centre commercial un mur
de force qu'il n'avait jamais prévu ou
imaginé il a rencontré des ukrainiens quand les
dictateurs
ne paient pas le prix de leur agression
ils causent plus de chaos et le coût des
menaces contre l'amérique et l'amérique
au monde ne
cesse d'augmenter
c'est pourquoi l'alliance de l'otan a été créée
pour assurer la paix et la stabilité en europe
après la seconde guerre mondiale il pensait que l'ouest
et l'otan ne répondraient pas il pensait qu'il
pouvait nous diviser à la maison mais poutine avait
tort
nous sommes prêts nous sommes unis et c'est ce
que nous  sommes-nous restés unis à tous
les américains
je serai honnête avec vous comme j'ai toujours
promis que je le serais nos forces ne sont pas
engagées et ne s'engageront pas dans le
conflit avec les forces russes en ukraine
nos forces ne vont pas en europe pour combattre
l'ukraine mais pour défendre  nos alliés de l'otan
les états-unis et nos alliés
défendront chaque pouce de territoire qui est le
territoire de l'otan avec toute la force de
notre pouvoir collectif chaque pouce
vous